حضر العسكر وغابت عضلات روسيا العسكريه في
يوم النصر مشهد يختلف عن سابقه
عرض يوم النصر الروسي من دون دبابات ولا
انظمه دفاع جوي مقاتلات سلاح الجو غابت عن
سماء الساحه الحمراء كما غابت ايضا
الصواريخ بعيده المدى باستثناء صاروخ يارس
الحفل لم يدم سوى اربعين دقيقه صخب اقل
وهدوء اكثر بل وصمتم كما وصفته صحف غربيه
حتى في مدن اخرى الغيت الاحتفالات
بدا واضحا ان قلقا يسيطر على الحفل قلق قد
ياتي محملا بمسيرات كما وقع قبل ايام حين
وصلت مباني الكرملين وهذا ما يفسر انتشار
هذه القوه المدججه باسلحه مضاده للمسيرات
على اسطح مباني محيطه بالساحه الحمراء
[موسيقى]
التاسع من مايو لم ياتي بجديد ميدانيا كي
يضيفه الرئيس بوتين في خطابه فلا باخمه
سقطت كما كان يشاع ولا الغرب اوقف مساعدته
لكييف بل اعلن البنتاجون عن مساعدات جديده
لاوكرانيا بقيمه مليار و200 مليون دولار
اليوم حضارتنا مره اخرى تشهد نقطه تحول
حاسمه وتندلع حرب حقيقيه مره اخرى ضد
وطننا لكننا قومنا الارهاب الدولي
على بعد 2200 كيلومتر من موسكو تمت دعوات
اوروبيه لعدم الخشيه من استعراض بوتين
لقوته المستشار الالماني اولى فشولز قال
ان الاستعراض يجب الا يرهب الاتحاد
الاوروبي حثما الاتحاد على الاستمرار
الحازم في دعمه لاوكرانيا مهما طال الامر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات